some of the heaviest fighting has been
underway on the strategically important
south coast of ukraine russian forces
have run into fierce resistance my
colleague chris livesay is in that hard
hit region chris
good morning charlie russian forces are
hammering ukraine's coastal cities like
here and mika live once again the scene
of overnight shelling it's a city at the
crossroads between odessa ukraine's
biggest port and a city that russia
desperately wants and marieuple a city
russian forces have already encircled
here mikalaya if people are doing all
they can to brace for and survive what
ukraine is calling russia's war of
annihilation
the video is silent but you can still
hear the horror the war in mary opal
alone has left more than 2 000 civilians
dead in a once thriving port city in
ruins
an elementary school was here says dima
a local resident there were no military
at this school
this footage from ukraine's national
guard shows its armored vehicles going
toe-to-toe with russia's zig-zagging
residential streets turned into a
concrete battlefield
the brutal urban warfare has left
hundreds of thousands of civilians
trapped in the freezing cold without
heat water food and electricity
and while the bombing is chillingly
indiscriminate it's also by design one
by one putin's forces are terrorizing
ukraine's port cities on his war path to
odessa but to get there he has to get
through or around nikolayev first
but not if the local governor vitaly kim
has anything to say about it here he is
showing off a captured russian tank
posting regular charismatic videos on
social media that go viral in ukraine so
what have you learned about the russians
from this last week militarily was the
last week i learned what is military
at all because i didn't i was a civilian
i know nothing about war
two weeks ago
now he knows it all too well nicolaive
has been the scene of fierce shelling
for days this weekend killing at least
four people hiding in a bomb shelter
beneath a school
governor kim has asked citizens to
donate their old tires to be set on fire
and disorient the enemy in case of a
full-on invasion and they listen
he also has a few ukrainian tanks of his
own
the charisma of ukraine's local leaders
is a powerful weapon and vladimir putin
knows this it's why ukraine says russia
has already abducted two of its local
mayors with the goal of installing two
pro-russian puppets
in their place
tony
crystal say for us in ukraine chris
thank you very much